breaking news intel a 220 billion dollar
industry leader is jumping into the
bitcoin mining industry wait this is
very very important obviously the
bitcoin hash rate has been exploding
after china banned mining in their
country last year we've hit all-time
highs and hash rate and it's only
growing faster and faster here in the
united states we've been the biggest
winner texas now has about 10 of all
bitcoin mining hash rate within their
borders and of course the u.s portion of
bitcoin mining is growing but intel
they're not going to sit on the
sidelines they've been producing gpus
previously which have been used to mine
other types of cryptocurrencies but now
intel is going after the asic market
asics application specific integrated
circuits these are computers that are
only built to mine bitcoin they just
announced that they have a brand new
bonanza mine chip that they're going to
unveil at a brand new conference the
isscc conference that is the annual
gathering of the best minds in the chip
industry so what exactly does this mean
well intel obviously knows a thing or
two about creating chips and according
to the report that is out now this brand
new chip will be a processor that has an
ultra low voltage energy efficient
powering a bitcoin mining asic so if all
of a sudden you have that ultra low
voltage when you're consuming less power
and it's super efficient meaning you get
more profitability per kilowatt hour
that you consume this could change the
game for bitcoin miners now of course
most of the people who are creating
bitcoin mining equipment previously
they're out in asia things like bitmain
etc but now they're going to have intel
as a competitor my guess is that intel
saw not only the boom in bitcoin mining
but they also understand that if they
can actually process these chips in a
competitive way they'll be able to
integrate them into all sorts of
different pieces of hardware to see
intel that 220 billion dollar company
getting in the game this is a massive
tailwind if we can get the cost of the
chips down we can get the cost of the
miners down it means that we can open up
access and reduce friction for more
people mining bitcoin as more miners
come online both in the united states
and globally it means that the bitcoin
network is more secure the more secure
the network is the more valuable it
becomes ultimately a move like this is
the democratization more people become
miners more minors secure that network
the network becomes more valuable i
think that intel coming into this is
going to end up being one of those
milestone moments when we look back 10
15 20 years from now and we're gonna say
remember when the big dogs started
jumping into bitcoin mining intel is the
first one but there will be many more to
follow